[Musique]
avec seulement tellement jour bonjour
patrice vous êtes l'auteur le metteur en
scène de la comédie musicale
naturia comédie musicale et florales ont
les floral
qui sera jouée ou au palais des congrès
le 22 décembre prochain alors je peux
donner je vais d un petit peu l'argument
et puis on va voir une bande annonce
mais une catastrophe écologique qui se
produit sur terre y est plus d'oxygène
toute la famille respirer et tous les
pays se mettent d'accord pour envoyer un
personnage qui s'appelle le commando
matteo exact aller chercher dans une
planète qui s'appelle nature ya là la
fleur de lumière qui va permettre de re
faire pousser les arbres dégénéré la
nature les faut ramener sur terre voilà
on regarde un peu là la bande-annonce
aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça pourrait être une scène netflix
offre être sa peau d'une un drame que
que nous risquons de vivre aussi un mets
mais parlons d'abord de la comédie
musicale parce que c'est un
convient sans personne à peu près le
haut niveau du d'hubert de l'équipe
global oui mais sur scène on est une
trentaine trentaine a une particularité
c'est effectivement la première comédie
musicale et florales du genre tellement
c'est à dire que tous les décors et les
tenues sont réalisées par des
fantastiques designer floraux des
artisans fleuristes
et c'était justement pour nous une
attache très importante parce que
concéder la nature est tellement belle
comment essayer par l'émotion de
sensibiliser le grand public à
l'importance de préserver cette beauté
et comment pouvoir la faire danser et la
mettre en lumière voilà était sale et
l'objectif c'est ça très nouveau on n'a
pas dit que la musique de jean jacques
fut très jean-jacques littéraire c'est
l'autre moitié naturia on a on à moi
j'ai eu l'idée au départ on s'est
rencontré en 2008 et et puis il ya une
alchimie exceptionnel et on
naturia c'est lui c'est pour ça qu'ils
venaient féliciter mais je reviens ce
que vous disiez au fond quand on parle
d'écologie quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique va des ddd
catastrophe qui peut nous arriver on en
parle de façon rationnelle parfois en
faisant pas et c'est vrai que l'émotion
c'est aussi une façon de mobiliser je
pense que prendre conscience nous on a
trouvé que c'était un sujet important
que tout le monde parle on a écrit ça en
mais on a trouvé aussi que le sujet est
traité de manière extrêmement
institutionnelle très conventionnel très
concurrentiel au final presque ça
s'adresse à un public élitiste nous ce
qu'on souhaitait c'était lui donne une
approche beaucoup plus populaire que
s'adresse à un grand public d'un enfant
3 4 ans jusque les grands parents et oui
c'est familial et c'est là où on a
réussi je pense le pari de de mettre en
avant d'abord le côté émotionnel je
pense que par l'émotion peut faire
tellement passer deux messages
sans pour autant rentrer dans la
moralisation des choses parce que les
centraliser
santé venez voir et vous allez ressentir
quelque chose alors c'est marrant que
vous disiez ça parce qu'une des phrases
est très important vous ressentez
respirer écoutez votre coeur dans le
spectacle régulièrement
c'est parfaitement ça à tel point que
maintenant on fait même d'ailleurs
l'objet de projets pédagogiques dans les
écoles donc l'émotion pour moi est un
vecteur extrêmement intéressant et du
coup en fait on a on n'a pas besoin de
rentrer comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure dans la moralisation des choses
des gens s'approprient le message par
eux-mêmes et ces deux mêmes qui se
disent il faut faire quelque chose il
faut faire quelque chose c'est ça ouais
c'est faire prendre conscience aux gens
malades papa par l'émotion et prendre
conscience au fond il ya aussi une moc
hiver que tous ensemble le tous ensemble
c'est très important on peut pas
personnel monopole des bonnes actions on
va pas changer le monde demain matin à 8
heures avec un spectacle
par contre on peut peut-être y arriver
tous ensemble et si alors naturia
peut être connecteur de ses plus
ensemble pour pour non pas pour nous
mais pour l'avenir de nos enfants alors
on serait on serait satisfait même si
quelque part au fond de nous on aurait
aimé jamais devoir imaginer ce spectacle
pour sensibiliser sur ce sujet important
que vous avez commencé à imaginer
naturia c'était c'était ça qu'elle vous
aviez dans votre esprit oui en fait j'ai
voulu d'abord moi écrire un spectacle
pour ma fille ah oui qui s'appelle cet
hymne et comment ne pas penser à demain
à l'avenir quand on devient papa c'est
pas qu'on devient parent
et l'amour de la scène a fait forcément
corps il fallait que j'écrive quelque
chose et j'essaie d'imaginer ce monde
presque utopiste mais
je me suis dit voilà j'aimerais écrire
un monde où ma fille ces enfants
pourraient peut-être y vivre plus
sereinement donc c'est parti un peu de
là en finale le projet et après je suis
un amoureux de la nature je suis un
amoureux des belles choses et j'avais
besoin de faire danser cette nature de 2
dollar m 2 2 devant devant les gens pour
rappeler à quel point elle est belle à
quel point on a le devoir de la
préserver
le spectacle créé en 2014 alors non moi
j'ai commencé à écrire en 2007 la
rencontre avec jean jacques federer a eu
en 2008 on aura mis six ans pour sortir
la première date l'a promis 14 effet
parmi vous avez raison 23 2014 en alsace
ouais on aurait reçu un accueil
exceptionnel parce que la daf est très
attaché six heures parce que je pense
que c'est difficile à monter quand même
c'est très difficile quand vous n'avez
pas de moyens et que j'avais juste 2 des
intentions et la passion c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais au final
c'est jamais renoncer un nom on peut pas
renoncer sur un sujet comme celui là et
encore moins quand on écrit un spectacle
pour sa fille
et puis on a fait des très belles
rencontres artistiques des rencontres
humaines et on s'est rendu compte que
les gens à adhérer à la philosophie et
je me suis dit au final nous ne créons
pas un spectacle j'ai pas envie que les
gens viennent voir un spectacle au final
mais j'ai envie qu'ils vivent une
expérience je sais d'expérience et un
voyage initiatique et combat vu plus de
son but
les floralies internationales de nantes
que craignent qu'on ne peut que
remercier nous avoir invités en 2019 à
la 12ème édition où on a fait treize
soirées consécutives à guichet fermé
1700 personnes chaque soir
ça a été pour nous
une éclosion ça a été une queue par un
remerciement de tout ce travail que que
la tribu nature et moscou mais ces
tribus vous dis c'est une famille ses
débuts nous reste prévue avec des
valeurs avec des valeurs auxquelles nous
tenons
donc oui c'est une tribu ouais santé et
une tribu et ça veut dire que tout le
monde adhère quoi tout le monde est dans
le même
sens
c'est ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné
on a eu rapidement l'envi de dire quand
on joue il faudrait qu'on puisse aussi
offrir une séance à des personnes qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'aller voir le
spectacle c'est pour ça qu'on a commencé
à initier à des séances solidaire c'est
à dire des sens comme on va faire le vin
le 21 on offre l'intégralité des
lorsque je pense que la culture c'est un
droit pour tous ont accès à la culture
pour tous c'est important et c'est
toujours rattachés à cette philosophie
de tous ensemble de de se dire qu'on
n'est pas seuls au monde et
développement durable s'est fait d'abord
ce qui nous entoure mais vous avez
raison de dire que ça dépasse le
spectacle est une sorte par l'émission
enfin cessé il ya un peu ce à quoi
dedans c'est devenu un message où il
s'agirait je suis devenu au fil du temps
je pense un peu porteur de ce message
mais une fois encore personne n'a le
monopole des bonnes actions
j'ai juste trouvé en survie métis touché
peut-être un plus grand nombre de
personnes et on n'en mènera pas nos
enfants tout un week-end dans des
conférences par contre on les emmène
deux heures et deux heures un peu moins
même
ouais il fallait aller un peu plus loin
je pense l'idée de rendre non plus les
gens spectateurs mais de les rendre
acteurs c'était quelque chose
d'important pour nous quand on prend la
décision de reverser un euro sur chaque
billet est là mais voilà un nom pareil
pour faire pousser des arbres sur les
lieux où on va se produire à ce moment
là les gens deviennent vraiment acteur
c'est important de rose ça des
spectateurs sont aussi des acteurs jean
vicky nature et des acteurs et non pas
des spectateurs qui la partie ne peut à
la tribu quoi oui c'est sûr des colibris
ce sont des colibris et l'idée de
reverser un euro territoire aux villes
via des associations via des villes pour
qu on plante des arbres en coeur de
ville c'était pour nous
logique et cohérente nicolas si au
regard jeudi c'est quand même un gros
barnum à
mettre en scène
c'est un énorme boulot quand même mais
vous vous êtes habitué à ça vous allez
de travailler avec des gens comme sting
com
tara johns kabadi endémique gitta exact
c'est 2014 on en 2003
c'était à nice mais combien de 65000
personnes c'est pour la fête de la
musique de nice était 2004 voilà j'ai
toujours été dans ce métier un peu
régisseur présentateurs animateurs
l'agencé gamma régis est devenu
animateur radio et puis un jour j'ai dû
toucher un peu comme vous voit la télé
assis sur des chaises musicales et puis
je suis partie accompagné des artistes
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle le warm up
c'est à dire le chauffeur de salle et
puis j'ai tellement aimé ça que j'ai eu
envie à mon donner des d'écrire mes
propres histoires mes propres concepts
mais les propres spectacles
donc donc oui et puis ccc c'est quelque
chose de fabuleux comme univers mais
j'avais pas envie d dans ce métier pour
refaire une énième comédie musicale
refaire ce qu'on a déjà vu un milliard
de fois j'avais envie de créer quelque
chose qui n'existe pas et qui deviennent
quelque chose au profit de tous on veut
et ça s'appelle donc naturia économique
on pourrait dire on pourrait rajouter
ouais comédie musicale floral écologique
et politique
ouais non pas parce que c'est ça s'il ya
de la poésie aussi c'est marrant parce
que les chercheurs ont commencé à voir
pousser
sans faire de jeu de mots mais contact
nature ya souvent un parent et un
spectacle écologique et on a trouvé ça
chouette mais c'est effectivement soumis
à envisager qu ici on veut de la poésie
voilà donc vous serez donc le 22
décembre sur la scène du palais des
congrès à versailles il ya une tournée
oui après on va jouer en france on va
jouer aux arènes de metz on va jouer au
zénith de rouen on va jouer à marseille
on va jouer
sur le site de sur le passé de cet axe
www.spectaclesjoliette.com
natura2000 a donc c'est excellent mental
célèbre intel com
merci infiniment merci à vous et à vos
spectateurs qui j'espère seront là
j'espère qu'ils vont vous dire voilà le
22 décembre au palais des congrès de
versailles merci beaucoup avec celle
montables merci patrice
[Musique]